us präsident donald trump fordert
vehement den bau einer mauer zu mexiko
das mag manchen überraschen weltweit
gesehen ist es aber kein einzelfall denn
grenzbefestigungen sind aktueller denn
je
heute in vechta kompakt die rückkehr von
zäunen und mauern vor knapp 30 jahren
wurde die berliner mauer niedergerissen
oder eiserne vorhang symbolträchtig
zerschnitten wer hätte gedacht dass
grenzbefestigungen so rasch wieder an
bedeutung gewinnen können durch
globalisierung und die damit verbundenen
freiheiten haben zu überforderung zu
ängsten geführt auch zu angst vor
staatlichen kontroll verlust die
terroranschläge von meinem leben haben
gewissermaßen eine zäsur bedeutet und
diesen trend noch verstärkt gab es 1989
16 befestigt die grenzanlagen zu
sprechen wir hier von mehr als 70 die
schon in betrieb sind im bau oder in
planung
weltweit 26 tausend kilometer mauern um
zu einer das sind ungefähr zehn prozent
der gesamten weltweiten grenzgängen die
hier 68 staaten voneinander trennen
der bau von grenzanlagen es mittlerweile
auch in boomender wirtschaftszweig 2015
betrug das auftragsvolumen in etwa 15
milliarden euro in vier jahren sollen es
schon knapp an die 30 sind also eine
verdoppelung
angesichts dieser größenordnung an
stellt sich die frage wozu
grenzbefestigungen dienen
historisch betrachtet stand verteidigung
im vordergrund
man denke an die alte chinesische mauer
an den römischen grenzwall oder auch die
maschine
es ging darum territorien abzusichern es
ging darum handels flüsse zu
kontrollieren aber auch wanderbewegungen
unter kontrolle zu haben
heutzutage steht der kampf gegen unter
schutz vor transnationalen terrorismus
im vordergrund es geht auch um die
bekämpfung der organisierten
kriminalität stichwort drogen und
menschenschmuggel und nicht zuletzt will
man damit auch eine kontrolle von
starken migrationsströmen erzielen
können
zu erwähnen ist auch noch die
symbolische bedeutung von
grenzbefestigungen sie sollen nach
innen beruhigen und nach außen abhalten
einige aktuelle beispiele dazu am
meisten strapazierte grenze zwischen den
usa und mexiko gesprächen von 3.000 144
kilometer das ist von paris bis ins
schwarze meer
1000 kilometer davon sind bereits durch
zu einer und mauern gesichert und möchte
man den rest ausbauen würde das mehr als
20 milliarden us dollar kosten
die regierung argumentiert mit dem
schutz vor drogenschmuggel von
menschenschmuggel vor terrorismus aber
auch vor einem staatlichen kontroll
verlust in folge unkontrollierte
migration zu einem anderen beispiel die
grenze zwischen indien und bangladesch
beträgt an die 4.100 kilometer heute
schon steht dort der längsten der welt
3000 kilometer er wird in kürze
fertiggestellt werden
indien argumentiert mit der angst vor
drogen und menschenschmuggel vor den
migrations ansturm der nicht
kontrollierbar wäre aber auch mit
transnationalen terrorismus
ein beispiel aus dem nahen osten seit
2014 hat saudi arabien die modernste
grenzbefestigung der welt über eine
länge von 900 kilometer wurden drei
linien von zäunen errichtet und in sand
wahl in einer höhe von sieben metern
gegenüber dem irak kosten geschätzte
zwei milliarden dollar
begründung das chaos aus dem irak nicht
ins land kommen zu lassen und schutz vor
den transnationalen terrorismus
aber auch in europa selbst innerhalb der
eu werden wie der grenzbefestigungen
errichtet infolge des außergewöhnlichen
migrations ansturms 2015 hat ungarn die
grenze gegenüber serbien durch einen
zaun abgesichert und 40 kilometer der
grenze gegenüber grazien budapest
betonte heute dass sie jederzeit auch in
den zaun gegenüber rumänien errichten
könnte sollte es hier zu einer
verlagerung von migrations rücken kommen
werden daher noch mehr zäune und mauern
gebaut werden die vereinten nationen und
die eu sehen diese entwicklung sehr
kritisch vor allem im zusammenhang mit
migration
allerdings solange der andrang in reiche
länder an
und solange transnationaler terrorismus
als die größte sicherheitsgefahr
eingestuft wird werden mauern und zäune
und befestigungen im trend bleiben
dabei ist wohl ein staaten klar dass
dies nicht die lösung der großen
probleme darstellt allerdings können sie
eine gewisse kontrollfunktion ausüben
sie können vielleicht auch einen ab
heute effekte ziehen und sie können die
eigene bevölkerung beruhigen